- Me coming from Africa, I
came here to better my life.
And I feel like personally we need to stop
using the word racism when
we don't get something
or when something don't go our way
and just keep trying.
- Let me jump in real quick.
No disrespect, but racism exists
and I have to acknowledge it
and I can't just ignore it,
but what I can do is
not buy into the system.
(tense music)
(gentle music)
- [Interviewer] Step forward if you agree.
Slavery affected my family.
- Yeah. I mean that's just
evident in my last name King.
I mean that's the brand of the slave owner
that put that name on my
family all those years ago
and I'm still wearing it in those ways
along with the compounded,
you know, economic disparity,
social disparity, mental
trauma, all of that.
I mean, it's tethered forever.
- So to go back to slavery
and talk about post-traumatic
stress disorder,
it has never stopped.
So there is no post.
What my great-grandparents
were teaching my grandparents
who taught my mother who taught me
came from what they
learned through slavery.
So there's a lot of fear,
a lot of insecurity,
a fear of society, a
fear of law enforcement.
So slavery has made a major impact
where the low self-esteem
is consistently reoccurring.
I think for me growing up
in Los Angeles, California,
in the early 1960s,
there was a stereotype that
I didn't want to be Black.
I didn't wanna be African
because we come from
Africa or we're slaves.
So I want to be a Chinese boy.
I want to be Bruce Lee.
So growing up like that,
I didn't like myself and who I was.
I didn't like the color of my
skin or the way that I spoke.
So I emulated other people.
I want to be something that I was not.
- It's very saddening
when you can literally only
go back a couple generations
and then it's like the
documents just don't exist.
There's no record.
It's like, you know, my family
has completely been erased.
In that same point too, in
the time that we've been here,
we've created an incredible culture
and we have so many things to be proud of
and I always reframe the narrative myself
and I speak of my ancestors
that were enslaved
as you know doctors and healers
and just like, you know, we were taken
because we were talented.
- Right.
- You know.
- Because we had skills to offer
and we built this country, so.
- And still building.
That's something to take pride in, so.
- [Interviewer] Can the
disagreers step forward?
- Slavery didn't affect my family,
but we did suffer a different
type of slavery back home.
Like we went to colonization.
Like I am Bamileke.
There was a massacre of Bamileke.
You guys can look it up.
They kill like more than
300,000 of my people
because we didn't want to assimilate
to the French culture,
but it's still nothing compared
to what you guys' ancestor
like been through.
You know.
- I wouldn't wanna
minimize that pain though.
What you just said hurt me.
That 300,000 people were killed
because they would not conform
to the colonization of the French people.
So that is just as painful and hurtful
as the the trauma that we
suffered here in America.
- I can't share the same experience
that you have went
through and your family,
even though we also had
our own type of slavery.
We had Apartheid at the time,
you know, where the Dutch people took over
and they wanted to just have South Africa
and maybe and I think other countries
where we could only just speak Dutch.
It's somehow still happening.
Even now there's like
a place in South Africa
where it's called Orania, you know,
and it's just Dutch people there.
No Black person is even allowed there.
So we still somehow feel
that oppression even now,
but it's nothing compared to
what your ancestral history,
you know, has gone through.
I'm somehow happy that
you guys have forgiven it
even though you haven't forgotten it.
Have you forgiven it?
I mean that face is like.
(everyone laughs)
- But me personally, no I haven't,
but I wanna work through the change.
But no, I have not forgiven
because it's a system
- And it's understandable.
that's still going on.
And from what I'm hearing from you guys,
there's a system that's still
going on in Africa as well
and it's a war on us.
- [Interviewer] Racism is
the main cause of poverty
among Black people in America.
- Racism is a very big issue
that talking about it I'm
really trying to be careful
to not like say anything
that will be insensitive.
If opportunity is right here,
they will give it to people of other race
than African American and Africans too.
So if there's a job that
maybe have math requirement,
I feel like they'll pick an
Asian person or they believe,
"Oh, African Americans will
not dress appropriate",
so they will pick another person.
They will always like pick
people that are not Black
over people that are Black.
- And I also think,
I think the crucial like missing point
when we talk about economic disparity,
time, time is the most valuable currency.
And if you have like a stock,
that's like the American
dream is the stock
and you know during all
that time while that asset
the American dream was appreciating
and you're not allowed to
take out business loans,
you're not allowed to read,
you're not allowed to write.
You have to first fight to
become three fifths of a citizen.
Then you got Jim Crow and
then you got everything else.
It's like you're now having
to buy in at a price so high
because the time is irreparable.
You can't get that back.
One Black person today cannot
in one lifetime achieve
what generations of white
families were able to do
simply because they didn't have
to compete with us to do it.
- Yeah.
I agree with you totally like.
- Yeah
I was thinking just like you said
from a historical standpoint,
we start with slavery.
Then that's centuries,
generations of stolen labor
like you said.
Then we get into Jim Crow,
which is just an extension of that.
Then we have redlining.
We have mass incarceration.
We have events like the bombing of Tulsa
and Rosewood in Florida
and all these different examples
of our wealth being decimated.
And I don't say that to
come from a defeatist
or a victim mindset,
but I think if we just
have an honest conversation
about history and what we've gone through
when we've been here,
racism is definitely a big part of that.
And there are a lot of
successful Black Americans,
a lot of millionaires, a lot
of you know business owners,
but they're exceptions
for sure for a reason.
And there's a big difference
between income and wealth.
I would like to challenge the ideal
that African Americans are lazy
or that we don't have a good work ethic.
I think there's this perception
that, you know, we're here.
We're in America,
How are we not doing
better for ourselves, so?
- I thought I was gonna
be the only one staying.
I was gonna be like, "Oh I'm
about to be like Kanye West."
But okay, there's a lot of
thing we can use as an excuse
to hold us back to not
to reach our potential,
but it's up to us to look past that.
You know, like me coming from Africa,
I came here to better my life, my family.
I'm the only one here.
And since I have been here,
there's a lot of bad
things that happened to me.
There's also a lot of good
As African or African American,
we need to like look past like racism
and like just focus on our own goal.
Like what do we want to achieve?
And we need to stop using the word racism
when we don't get something
or when something don't go our way
and just keep trying, you know.
- Let me jump in real quick.
No disrespect, but racism exists
and I have to acknowledge it
and I can't just ignore it,
but what I can do is
not buy into the system.
You know, if I want to do something,
let me be the entrepreneur.
What I believe happened in the 1960s
is that we started
looking for equal rights,
to be equal with other people.
And what we stopped doing, and
I heard you talk about Tulsa,
we stopped using the
Black-owned businesses.
Now, because you guys gotta understand
the Fair Housing Act in 1968,
I'm five years old.
That's when we could move
off the east side of LA
and move into other subcultures.
So what I wanted to do at
eight years old was go to IHOP.
I didn't want to go to the
ma and pa restaurant anymore.
I want to go to let's
go eat at the hotels.
So what we did is stopped
supporting each other
and started supporting corporate America.
So the racism plays a major part,
but we don't have to buy into it.
- I have been waiting to
disagree with you, my brother.
I'm waiting patiently.
The thing is, even though I
want to disagree with you,
I get where you're coming from.
When I see Black people
talking about racism,
all that stuff,
I'll be like, "What is
wrong with these people?
You guys have food.
You have EBT, all this thing
and you are here shouting
about somebody's racist
to just leave that person and move on."
I feel that way.
Like why are they always like complaining?
But when Black Life
Matters started happening,
like I sat down, I said,
"I need to actually know why
these people are pained."
And if we look at the history,
what they've done to them.
Like if you actually sit down,
watch some documentaries,
how they were I maltreated.
I don't think if I'm actually born there,
I will forgive those people.
I don't care.
It's easier for us Africans
that were raised in Africa
to feel like they're complaining
because we were raised through struggle.
Like I barely even have water.
And you, you have water,
you are complaining.
But then it's not about
the basic necessity
or about how we are raised.
We are raised like, I don't
want to say way better.
We might not have resources,
but there's some way,
like our own people
will not look down on us
or put us behind.
So it's in their nurture that way.
Like they just can't overlook it.
And if you sit down and watch everything
that the forefathers have
been through for you,
I change my mind.
No, they need to be angry.
However, they should still move forward.
- [Prosper] I mean, we have
police brutality back home too.
- True.
- We have, like if you go to Cameroon
and then you see how the
police officer like treat us
and they're Black just like us,
you're not even gonna believe it.
You know?
And in Cameroon we have this,
have you guys heard the
word like tribalism?
- Yeah, yeah
- It happens in Nigeria too.
- Yeah.
So we do get oppressed too.
- [Elizabeth] I agree.
- So when I'm saying like we
need to like look past that,
I'm not saying forget what
happened to you guys or me.
At the end of the day,
we cannot just sit and
just grieve on the past.
We have to be able to
move on, but not forget.
If I could choose a place to live,
it will obviously be my country.
I love my country,
but right now my country is
not the best choice for me.
There's a little genocide
going on in Cameroon right now.
So many innocent life have been taken.
If I was still in my country,
the opportunity that I have here
I would not have those opportunity there.
- [Interviewer] Hip-hop
reinforces stereotypes
about the Black community?
- In South Africa we have
our own version of hip hop,
so we call it (speaking foreign language).
So they would rap in our
own language, in different,
we call it (speaking foreign language).
So back home it kind of did
reinforce some stereotypes
because now when you go out in the world,
people will just classify
you under one group.
And growing up also looking
at American entertainment,
looking at the hip-hop that's done here,
I'm like, "Oh well, you're
rapping about drugs.
You're rapping about this."
Of course, it's gonna happen.
Of course, you're gonna go to jail.
But getting older you see the
culture as well of hip-hop.
I had to understand that
there's a culture within that.
- I was alive when hip-hop started
and it was during a time
where people rapped about what they saw,
what they wanted, what
they wanted in life.
And then it became where people rapped
about what they had been through,
what they had gotten over,
you know, used to sell drugs,
used to hurt people, but
now this is who they are.
And I think it's gotten into
now, in our day and age now,
it's where people are glorifying
and wanting to pretend
that these are the things
that they do on a daily
basis when it's not.
So it went from storytelling
to now really it's truly storytelling,
but it's unhealthy for our culture.
- I don't want to turn on my radio
and all I'm hearing is
I put a bullet in it,
something, something, like I'm like, "Eh?
That's what you could do."
No, like.
And then it's all about like
talking about female body type,
the booty, the tits.
Like don't talk about my booty like that.
So I don't want to listen
to something that portray me
as a female that way
or something that is talking about
how you put bullets in my head.
Like if you actually
do not come to America
and see for yourself,
you will think that most African Americans
are carrying guns around
and they just shoot randomly
or they just grab your (beep)
or something like that.
That's the way the music portray them.
And music is a very important
element in our society
'cause it influence a lot of
people, both youngs and adult.
And then they kind of see all those stuff
and they act like that
even though that's not what
they really want to be.
They act like that and behave like that.
Like if all these rappers
are your role model,
then you wanna be like them.
You wanna be cool too.
So in the end,
it's about like the people
that are packaging the music
and sometimes about trend
is what people want to hear.
- [Interviewer] The American
dream is only for white people.
- I believe that the American
dream is only for white people
because it says equal.
And when we talk about equal,
there's no equality between the 1%,
the Rothschilds, the
Rockefellers, the Trumps,
and the people who really run the media
and things of that nature.
So for Black people growing up in America
and living in America,
we could become rich,
we could become wealthy,
but we are not on the equal
playing field of white America.
The system of white supremacy
which is in the law enforcement,
which is in the judicial system,
which is in the prison
industrial association,
also in the politics,
we are not equal in any of those terms.
- When I was back there
and when you were speaking,
I started thinking like,
"Could we ever actually
as Black people have the
American dream here in America?"
And I don't know if we really can being,
I'm trying to be careful with my words,
but I do think there needs
to be a degree of separatism,
like Black people we
really need to have our own
to fully take part in that dream.
- [Skipp] This is their system.
- Yeah.
- Why would we dream of
being equal in a system
that wasn't designed for us?
- The American dream, at least
the way that I define it,
is you know, freedom of opportunity,
freedom to choose what
I what I want to do,
freedom to acquire wealth the same way
that anybody else can.
Obviously, we're fighting
the tides of time on that
in our circumstances,
but it's hard because
it's hard to honor that,
but then also want more for myself.
And I think that as Black people,
we're always teeter-tottering
on that line of like,
"Well, am I American?
Like do I get the American dream
or do I, do we just tear
all this (beep) down
and build something new?"
White people are not
the only people entitled
to the American dream ever.
- [Lethabo] Yeah.
- And I think that
that's why we're all here
because our ancestors made it so
that we can stand here and
pursue that American dream.
- I wouldn't have been here
if it meant that it was not for everyone.
I wouldn't have even entered America.
You know, I feel like not just African,
but other people as well
in different countries.
And from what I have seen,
I've seen other people, even Africans
and African Americans
succeeding in their own way.
And that's why I feel like,
like you said you can
interpret the American dream
in a different way,
whatever industry or whatever
it is that you're focusing on
because there is a level
of opportunity there.
There is some way that
you can be successful.
You know, talking about
Trevor Noah, you know,
who took over "The Daily Show".
It wouldn't have been possible for him
coming in as an African.
He got his American dream.
It made us as well,
other Africans believe
that it is possible.
- The American dream writes his check,
so he gets to have wealth
or whatever it is that he's experiencing,
but the American dream is the one
who writes his check, not him.
- Hmm.
- I agree with you.
I hear you.
(everyone laughs)
But do you see how
- But you can
- we would put it
- reach for the stars.
as he had his American dream
even though someone writes his check.
- I understand.
- But for him
or for some of us looking
at it on the other side,
that's his American dream because
his goal was to get there.
The biggest cultural
shock I saw coming here
was definitely the lifestyle
because the lifestyle I saw of America,
especially Los Angeles,
was portrayed as a very rich lifestyle.
And of course I came here as a student
and coming here, living here
and seeing the reality of it,
seeing different homeless
people, disadvantaged people,
was really a cultural shock for me
because I didn't expect to see that.
And I guess also the way
people were handling each other
because coming in as an African
I thought people were together.
But since being here,
I saw that there was a huge divide
or there is still a huge divide
within the African American
community themselves.
- If he had stayed in South Africa,
would he have had the same
opportunity that he had here?
- No.
- Like, you know, so corporate
is writing his check.
But like us growing up,
the reason we move here is
because we don't have it better back home.
But like for me,
I'm the first person ever
in my family in America.
Everybody else is back home.
Everybody's depending on me.
All of them, my mom,
she's dying to come here.
Like she willing to do
anything just for her
to be in America.
So for me, when I look at
those like little things,
I'm like, "Yeah, American
dream is for everybody".
You know.
Like, yeah, we might not
have the same opportunity
as do white people,
but there's still that little chance
that a lot of us back home
are willing to take just to get here.
- [Interviewer] I trust law enforcement.
(everyone laughs)
- I don't have a thing to say.
- [Interviewer] All right, can
the disagreers step forward?
- I got married to a young lady
who did 15 years in prison for
a robbery she didn't commit.
I myself was incarcerated for six months
for a burglary that I
couldn't have committed
because I was in prison.
So in 1987, I'm doing 19 months in prison.
When I came home in 1988, I
was given a burglary charge
and I had to sit six months
and the judge did not kick it out
because there's no way
I could have done it.
He kicked it out because they
didn't serve me the warrant
while I was in prison.
So I don't trust them.
They lying.
They do things and it affects our people.
So many people I know who
have been wrongfully arrested,
wrongfully convicted, and they
actually lie on the stand.
So there's no trust.
- As you guys know, I am
from Richmond, Virginia.
It was the capital of the Confederate.
I have been brutally
abused by the police there,
like personally,
I was at the river on the 4th of July.
I don't smoke.
I don't do none of that.
The police come and arrest me
because I look like a drug dealer.
Like they like arrested me.
- Wow.
- What?
The stereotype!
- Then when I was in high
school my senior year,
my father went to jail over a
car accident, a car accident.
And I was left alone at 17 years old.
I was grateful.
One of my teacher took
me in and like raised me.
I try to stay away from the
police as much as possible.
- First of all, they're human beings
and I think that just
because you put a badge on
that doesn't magically bewitch
you with like integrity
and a desire to actually
help the people around you.
I think a lot of times police culture
comes from police families.
It comes from like legacy lines
and this whole like kind of
like culture about stuff.
I mean, I don't trust them anymore
than I would trust any other person.
They haven't earned that necessarily,
especially not as an institution.
In its purest form, I
think it's necessary,
but they have a lot of
living up to that to do
and to make up for if
they're gonna be trusted.
- 'Cause I've seen law
enforcement here on social media
and seeing how they treat
people of color, you know,
from like hitting them.
I mean George Floyd,
you know, rest in peace.
But just seeing that from
my experience being here,
I was scared, you know.
Like every time I'd see a cop car pass by,
I'm like, "Okay, I better
make sure I'm driving okay,"
you know, 'cause I don't wanna be stopped
or make sure you're not in
any harm's way, you know.
But it's sad to feel that,
to feel that pressure every
time you see a cop going by
and even if they trying to help,
but I wouldn't even want that help
because of what I've been seeing
on social media, you know.
And also seeing the case
of people being wrongfully,
you know, taken to prison.
That's like unfair.
Like what type of research are you doing
before you arrest people?
- And I immediately
thought about the history
of the police too,
just tracing that back to slave patrols,
which became our modern
day police departments.
- Or the fact that like
if you have a felony,
you can't vote.
Like that to me is like
talk about the loss of the American dream.
Like you are a citizen of this country.
You should always have a right to vote.
- [Interviewer] We are
obsessed with race in America.
- I think that word obsessed
is such an interesting word.
And I think that the way
that that question is framed
is almost as if it's
like the onus is on us.
Like we are obsessed with race too much.
Like no white people are obsessed
with race in this country.
They've made their laws based on it.
They've cast us out because of it.
They've like destroyed
entire groups of people
because of it.
So I mean, we're just
living in the ripple effects
of the stones that were
cast in the pawn of history.
So we're just reacting to it.
So we would rather just be human beings
than American citizens
and, you know, people that are
pursuing an American dream,
we'd rather not have to think about race,
but that we did not draw
first blood on that.
- What else do you expect
given the history of it?
- Yeah, like, I mean,
I'm not obsessed. (laughs)
- Yeah.
- For me being in America
and give me opportunity to like meet
and like discover so
many different culture
that I would never see
if I was in my country.
I would just like maybe
hear about it on the news.
Yes, I agree.
I think they are very obsess with race.
Even when you do like a easy application,
like it doesn't matter
what application you do,
they want to know your race.
They want to know, you know,
why they don't have a
category for Africans?
- Exactly.
- You know
- That's why I'll be
checking out the same time.
- Yeah.
- They wanna know everything.
- The thing that pissed me off the most is
that when they see you
and they'll be like,
"Oh you have an accent.
Where are you from?"
Like, who cares where I'm from?
Just sell me this and let me keep going.
- And when you tell them
that you're African,
they'll be like, "What country?"
- Yeah, they're so obsessed
with where you're from.
- She's like "Wakanda".
(everyone laughs)
- I don't believe that
there's an obsession
about race in America.
I believe that race is a
distraction to hide the power,
the wealth, and the access to it.
So a lot of times there's
something put on the table,
like a rock being thrown
and I hold my hand
and that's the racism
between Black and whites,
between Blacks and Hispanic
and other cultures who have come here.
We'll talk about race just
so that we don't have access
to the power and the wealth.
And I think it's done on purpose.
There's a power that allows
us to talk about race
if we don't look past it.
- Some of the question
prompt that I see differently
and then when I hear
somebody say that I'm like,
"Mm, that actually makes sense
coming from their perspective."
So it's been really beautiful
having this conversation
with you guys.
You guys are very knowledgeable
and I've learned a whole lot from each
and every one of you today.
- Going into this with like
the title of the series,
like African versus African American,
I think that like people
were gonna come in thinking
that we were gonna be like guns blazing,
but this is such a
beautiful display of unity.
I love it.
It like gave me so much life today.
(gentle acoustic music)